and fundamentals of Investments that's a
different story small amount of money
and a big amount of money we're pretty
good at that what a ride cashing out
we don't know how to do it
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another great
episode of the careful boys where we are
currently
we're good wow keep that as a sound bite
from now on we should just play that
regardless of people mouth it let's use
it
recommend continuity man yeah
all right that being said we're doing
our final part three of
the first quarter of 2023 is over let's
get a live catch up on we gotta hear
from Steve and Joe and maybe if we got
room for okay content Nick can go again
so Steve how you been man I'll be good
buddy I'm I'm actually I'm actually good
I um
I'm excited oh I told you I was very
excited right now because I am
interviewing the community manager for
woo my favorite crypto uh next week on
me and Nikki's podcast
they're excited about it he's coming to
be on your show it's gonna be on my
podcast yeah we're doing it remotely
because he's like in another country but
it's but I'm very stoked on it because
um I've been following the project for a
long time I've been carrying the project
in my back forever so it'll be
fun it'll be really fun is he like
you've been the poster boy for woo
where'd you get that idea I don't know
it's weird do they share it do they
share the JK news stuff all the time
because of what you're wearing and what
you're doing I don't know but I mean
it's definitely been shared like they
put me in their Community thing and they
call it JK Woos JK Wu but I um yeah it's
just cool because it's I mean you know
like I remember I was in this room
um when they tweeted that I was wearing
this nft hoodie and then it's like cool
to get to talk to the guy because where
are they based out of all over but not
China taiwan's part of it right which is
China got you Joe oh and
um am I right boys let's go
can we send this to Jackson Wang's team
for swim we're sweating right they'll
like that yes cut this clip it so this
is actually the same thing yeah they're
like this is good no but um they're
all over they kind of have like 200 I
think just about 200 employees but
they're all based all over the
place decentralized like one would hope
thank God they're not in the United
States of America where cryptos being
cracked down upon right now Big Time SEC
operation choke point like they're
really coming after crypto stuff so it
feels good knowing that I'm not you know
it's not in the United States so I don't
have to sweat it as much so yeah wow
that's pretty cool how did Nikki take
the whole thing that you like hate
Filipino food yeah she laughed
unfortunately
I know she knew you were serious or what
I'm a dull knife
you know what I mean like it's like it
doesn't work anymore I've just been
cutting her so many times with like the
same jab and it's like oh yeah it
doesn't work she seems resilient then
she is she really is yeah she's used to
but then um yeah no it's great I I'm I'm
doing good like um Nikki's obviously the
best I mean like everything there's
always amazing she's still the major
Breadwinner for the house major
Breadwinner yep she's making the poker
Queen she makes the bread Prince the
money yeah poker white has she been
playing any more tournaments she's been
playing tournaments yeah it's it's it's
definitely like tournament season about
to be because because when she won last
year it was like May yeah so like it's
coming into World Series of Poker right
now so she's kind of getting ready for
that it's kind of like how an athlete
trains for anything like they go and
they're like train huh yeah oh wow and
like it's like breaking a sweat and
stuff like that just moving chips around
dude it's a lot I respect you know I
like
I like to make fun of everything
obviously but knowing so much more about
it about poker especially I'm like man
these guys are really they work their
asses off like and it's I know people
just want to be like ah just gambling
and but dude poker is such a
game out there like it's crazy
It's a Grind like Joe Knows like it's a
girl it used to be one of my
favorite sports to watch on ESPN yeah it
was it's intense I still dude I'll sit
there I've watched a four hour long
poker stream with Nikki it's just really
I I think that it's one of the better
Sports dramatically like visually
because the Flop is so interesting and
the way the turn comes like it's really
dramatic and every time I'm hanging out
with poker people now I'm always like
you guys don't get as much respect as
you deserve as far as the entertainment
aspect of Poker it's very well I think
you gotta understand the game first and
then once you understand it that it's
like chess but then because of the way
it can be played it's almost has this
like Clint eastwood-esque Vibe right
once that flops and it's like when you
like look at what is this
gonna do and it's like cuts to the card
because of that guy you know it's like
literally like a like a
like Showdown and then they're like
chess
if you couldn't see the other players
pieces and what they got on the board
and you bet on every move you put a pawn
50 G's behind that part your own money
worth like honestly and there's natural
disasters on the board oh yeah so like
there's like you could play All the
Right Moves you could do all that in a
tornado and Battleship at the same time
the person checkmated with
all around their King and then a
tornado comes yup and saves them well
that's how statistics works right it's
like well this hand that has a 90 chance
of winning but statistics are like you
could flip a quarter 500 times and it
hits heads like you just don't know that
it's absolutely gonna hit Tails next
time you don't know don't know it's it's
wild like that so you know but people
you know and I've learned that that
statistics are like that recently I did
I can't say I always knew that because
like I remember whenever when Trump won
like the morning of New York Times is
like or it was like 5 38 Nate Silver's
firm they're like Hillary's gonna win 90
chance that you know or 92 chance or
some Trump has an eight percent
chance of winning he can't win basically
right everyone's climbing on it but then
he won so it's like yeah if you ran the
simulation 90 or 100 times Trump only
wins like eight percent of the time but
that can still happen and that's what so
people like clown that guy and they go
he's a idiot what a
idiot he thought like Trump was going to
lose but it's like that's how statistics
are dude like that's it can absolutely
yes the chances of it happening oh but
infinite infinite rounds exactly yeah
doesn't make that guy a idiot
because he was wrong it's just it's
fascinating because I used to think more
like less credible
what about what about turtles have you
killed any Turtles recently I'm not
thank God but I also haven't been
fishing recently and fishing season's
coming up
statistics again I'm scared
especially because my neighbor starts
talking about like how we're gonna try
getting catfish again I'm like dude we
never got one Cafe in your guys's Lake
there's a there's catfish in a guy's
Lake really that Lake looks like
Kool-Aid water what the you saying
about my leg dude are you serious you're
gonna tripping my property value down
right now no I'm just saying like you
look at the color of the water and
you're like someone put dye in there it
looks good I like that no because
you he put like a bag of dog food and
like threw it in the water the morning
up yeah and then like 10 hours later we
went to my buddy my buddy's place and
like fished off of his dock for Turtles
though he fished for Turtles well no we
were just trying to catch cats we're
trying to get catfish all we brought up
is turtles turtles were catching
just families of turtles just
screaming up the line
screaming can you eat the catfish in
there or no you probably wouldn't want
to eat any of this stuff coming out of
liquor well we can't
because it's Kool-Aid water well no
because because it's it's not supposed
to do that uh in this area you know what
your friends should do your neighbor
just stock
the the pond you know what he should do
what buy a fish put it in an aquarium
and try to catch it there then
we don't then we don't accidentally get
turtles yeah right that I think is a
good unless he accidentally buys turtles
because he could stock the pond wait and
then there are there's like gonna be a
ton of fish that he could catch well
they restocked the pond constantly
apparently with turtles exactly yeah
Turtles non-stop dude that must
have been horrifying it was my first pet
as a child it was a turtle I had a
turtle named Tommy the turtle
damn that's pretty hard which is also
most of my internet password
I'm in when you're when you're in Vegas
what do you occupy most of your time
with
okay so me and Nikki's podcast is like
my biggest like you know like we could
prep for it or whatever and then we do
it and then
um you know during the week it's mostly
just crypto like all as much as
research do yeah research about crypto
stuff I do crypto Corner every Tuesday
night 7 P.M Pacific Standard Time on
Tuesday
um so you do crypto like a stock Trader
like you're like researching looking at
charts I'm a value investor I don't try
I don't trade I mean like a like a stock
investor like that you're in it I'm in
it I'm in the game I mean I mean I look
at it as like I'm already beating me and
Nikki's 401K that's for damn sure
because I still watch my uncle just
stare at like tickers
and and he would just watch like
four screens for like four hours looking
at this red and green things I'm
like this is the most boring I never
want to do that yeah that's some day
trade how rich is he now
probably is that rich I think he sucked
at it oh day Traders scared me dude
because like you can I mean there are
some people God love you they're killing
out there good for you but I think my
method works better as far as like time
spent and and like you know value
investing making sure that you have a
lot of something so that when it takes
off you're part of the top of the rocket
so that you're getting the most value
out of your investment and like even if
you didn't buy the perfect low who the
does right you're capitalizing on
the low because you know why you bought
it that's the whole thing that's the
trick to the game that's what Warren
Buffett does like that's what all these
other guys do I think it works really
well that's why I've done it so many
times now turn a small amount of money
into a very big amount of money
um and yeah Luna got killed and stuff
like that but I still cashed out a lot
so like thank God but um thank you
Vladimir Putin thank you uh Ukraine war
I I freaked out I freaked out I had to
pull money out I was like I don't know
what's gonna happen and that was uh what
ended up saving me like big time
he kept me alive for the run right so
now it's like I'm trying to make sure
that I'm in the right move at all times
right so it's like you look around you
make sure that you you're analyzing what
the competitor is doing
but man I have to say like use case wise
like Woos has been up there the whole
time solving a real problem that crypto
has which is fragmented liquidity and
Woo is is you can consistently check it
is one of the top liquidity providers
for every pair that it has and it always
flips the switch and has a huge amount
of liquidity because of who's backing
them which is group called Chronos
they're huge Traders they do like five
to ten billion dollars of Trades a day
um and they incubated with so
it's a really exciting time right now in
crypto
um
so yeah especially now that the other
Banks aren't providing it so now the the
pool is shrinking on who's going to be
able to provide that liquid and a market
need is emerging right and that's that's
the game baby like you've got it but you
have to be paying attention and that's
that's the thing about it like you know
I I do spend a lot of time on crypto
because I want to make sure that I am
attuned to what the market needs that's
why every run so far I've done really
well because I knew what people were
wanting not because I'm so smart
or anything like that I'm actually just
paying attention to what the community
needs and I try to invest in that area
like it's not much more complicated than
that but it you know yeah it's work it's
it's but it's fun I love the
it's my hobby I love it so yeah
that's so cool yeah
and because of Steve he does the
homework and we dump the money in
Steve's picks and we win we all win
together it's been fun it's been fun now
cashing out and fundamentals of
Investments that's a different story
that's a different story right until we
die small amount of money to Big amount
of money we're pretty good at that what
a ride cashing out we don't know how to
do it we haven't gotten there we
literally don't know investing
fundamentals what
how are you buddy uh pretty amazing now
not that I wasn't but I've been uh it's
been a roller coaster at you know Hawaii
like
I've definitely bit off more than I
could chew I think um
it was one of those things where it was
a great time but also a scary time
because like uh once Luna got taken out
I think I only had
like 150k to my name I didn't have
left I mean it's that's a lot it is a
lot but this this is what I'm getting is
I still owed about
200k into building this project oh so I
had to figure out you know what what I
was gonna do took a loan out whatever so
I got wiped out as in like
whatever I had there
um it was all into jumby Hawaii so that
was my like I gotta make this
work if it does not work like I mean I
got JK but dude like
I don't know I I have no idea so that
was really scary it was the first time I
got to that point or maybe second
because after oh OMG I had a similar
experience but I got myself out of it
and then I think like now the store's
pretty much running like we got it going
all of my projections on the business
was like pretty uh close to Accurate
meaning like before you start the
business right you want to run your
comparison and think like
how much are these stores making what is
the likelihood of me making this much
it's just doing your homework and one of
the things is like it's it's one thing
that like
think about it and go would this work
and then you might feel that you're
right but unless you test it but then in
business the way you test it is you
gotta put money where your mouth is
right and then I don't know I was still
like I feel confident but I'm not sure
but I was able to hit all those points
and at the lowest we still broke even
so we had our worst month in February
November December was great profited the
first month
February broke even March profited so
I'm like if February is the like worst
traffic uh uh tourist season it can only
go up from here and so now I'm like oh
this is cool and I got to
experience like
opening up a new business was like I've
already done YouTube I've done internet
stuff digital content all that but
having like a store and running a team
building that all that was like
it's just something completely different
it's kind of the same but I mean I'm
sure you know you have a gym right like
it's like the physical world versus like
running an internet company it's a
nightmare it is
it's a deal with real people like a lot
I mean my team they're amazing
but yeah there's just a lot man it's
been yeah there's just a lot of things
that I didn't
think about well you told me about
training the employees was wild for you
for a little while yeah and I mean I
think also because I'm learning while
I'm training like when you're opening up
a store you're learning what you know
they're teaching you and then you're
trying to develop a system while you're
teaching them and then usually when
people you know train and get into a job
like other people are experienced so
then you have a bunch of people that
don't know what they're doing together
and then you just gotta make sure that
no one's like freaking out because you
literally made up the rules yesterday
yeah about it today and no one knows
what they're gonna see it if it works
tomorrow at least also corporate's not
with you because you guys are
have a good relationship with Jimmy
corporate right yeah but some people who
are doing franchise Chinese out there
it's like whoa that's a whole other
battle yeah yeah that's what I'm I feel
like super fortunate is like it's it is
literally like we're friends and family
like it's family members that bought
franchisees and like friends that got
together so yeah I I feel like they had
my back it was just like
it was just a crazy world and then now
I'm just snapping out of it like oh I
can relax now I've noticed that yeah
because I would get phone calls in the
middle of JK and I'm all like oh my God
the store's gonna burn down there was a
stretch where I had never seen any more
tired ever like ever you know what I
mean like you guys know was there like a
phase where like you feel like you're
the tension or anxiety was like an
all-time high and finally you're like oh
I could take a breath right now yeah it
was it was when I wasn't in Hawaii and
when I was in Vegas and there was a
stretch of like three months where I
couldn't do anything
um the store wasn't getting built we
were just draining money and
then like I felt like no control like my
all the power was in the hands of the
city giving waiting for the city to give
me approval and then I'm just calling
I'm just asking like when is it gonna
happen and then you got like our own
landlord pressuring so like it was like
being in this weird state of like you
have no power but everyone's looking at
you to make a decision but it's like not
in my hands yeah and all you can see is
your bank account just draining and
draining and draining and you're just
like when is it gonna end that was the
most scariest but
actually the easy part was like working
15 hours a day because there's something
about being able to do something like
working toward it and seeing things like
like incrementally get solved so like
let's say like you start seeing
equipment and things getting built in
your store even if things break like
it's getting fixed right so it's kind of
like that feeling of like progress yeah
like you're fixing something or like and
it becomes kind of therapeutic where
like there's problems and then most
people will say problems equal stress
and then I started feeling like oh let
me solve it because I love the feeling
of like I fix this now I feel better I
fix this now I feel better so I think
like
what I've learned from this whole
process is that
um when you're not doing anything it's
the most scariest and depressing but
when you can actually like work on
something every day
it's uh it's healing like mentally and
emotionally and then people think
working is stressful but I think not
working is actually stressful because
then when we were working like you can
see the movement and then it's like
being able to go out and do something
about it versus like just waiting and
waiting and waiting and like worrying
yeah that was killing me the most but
the cool thing is like I always dreamed
about
balancing my life out there and now it's
like I'm waking up and I'm like yo let's
just go swim for a workout and we're
just jumping in the water taking a quick
little outdoor shower and then like our
our shop is like right there a few steps
away from the beach so you just walk
around you check in on it oh you got to
do a few things here and then it's like
these cool little breaks like because of
how small Hawaii is right it's like you
could get up in the morning be in a
crazy beautiful hike jump in the
waterfall and then go to work and then
that balance is like this is this is
what I did this for yeah that's pretty
cool now you're finally getting a reap
all the rewards of being at home yeah
because the first three months even
um we weren't we were we were just
Waikiki that's it the shop and the
office
and in the only time I drove out was to
go to Costco or like to do deals or
something and then so I felt like I was
in LA still but then now it's like it's
changing it's changing yeah I could
skate to work I could ride my moped and
do this and then like it you know like I
don't know and pretty soon I'm gonna be
going spear fishing and then I connected
with uh some of the influencers out
there they're like yeah we're gonna go
deep sea fishing and doing this and that
so now it's like everything's coming
together where it's like you work hard
and now you get to play hard and then
this is the lifestyle that I wanted and
I'm gonna be able to achieve that very
soon yeah thank you jealous thanks guys
and then come down come down yeah unlike
unlike Nick where he comes down for five
days straight and sees me for one hour
but like you guys I saw you at the
wedding dude you're just a bad person I
think I'm a piece of I think Nick
if he could he would just drive by JK
and wave and then
you guys send me my check please
foreign